este cuarto mes de guerra lucran ya
comienza con todas las miradas en esa
región del donbass donde hace semanas
comenzó eso que se llamó la segunda fase
de esta invasión rusa este centro de
esta batalla se centra en este momento
especialmente por el control de la
segunda ciudad de la provincia de loja
antes de severodonezk que está siendo
rodeada por todos sus flancos por el
ejército ruso aunque en teoría hasta hoy
todavía sigue en control de las fuerzas
kenianas que se sienten cada vez más
asediadas y tienen menos posibilidad de
escape debido a que los puentes sobre el
río algunos de ellos están totalmente
destruidos pero esta batalla se extiende
hacia otras poblaciones el área de popa
en aquella fue capturada desde hace dos
semanas el control de las fuerzas rusas
se extiende también en todos sus flancos
y llega casi a la ciudad de bach mut que
se había convertido en el centro de
operaciones vas al centro de esa región
del donbass él ya la provincia de don ex
allí está siendo atacada esta población
permanentemente y la población que
quedaba allí la pobla quedaba ha sido
evacuada como también sigue sucediendo
en la ciudad de crematorios y también en
el globe yanks donde vienen los ataques
rusos por otro frente por el del norte
por el de la zona de zoom y la población
también está siendo evacuada ya lo
habíamos visitado días antes había muy
poca gente que quedaba allí pero en los
últimos días se han organizado caravanas
para evacuar a los que quedan